comme beaucoup d'organisation j'ai opéré
ma transition
tél alors non je ne suis pas devenu un
cyborg à la terminator ou à la ghost in
the shell
même si entre nous j'aimerais bien voir
la plastique de scarlett johansson et
non je ne me suis pas fait implanter en
modules d'intelligence artificielle ni
une boussole dans le torse après 15 ans
a travaillé au sein d'un service
marketing international j'ai entamé ma
révolution digitale
je me suis formé j'ai quitté le salariat
pour devenir consultante indépendante en
marketing et stratégie digitale un
véritable virage professionnel et même
personnel alors quand j'ai préparé cette
intervention pour être honnête je me
suis dit c'est un petit peu osé tu vas
parler transformation numérique à des
digital natives des jeunes qui sont nés
avec le digital débit les news comme les
gens aiment vous appeler c'est un pari
alors je le relève quand on parle
digital on associe en général un certain
nombre de termes souvent des anglicismes
d'ailleurs pour évoquer les techniques
et les technologies qui sont associés
blog shane crypto monnaie intelligence
artificielle haye outils internet of
things donc ce sont les objets connectés
marketing automation gros sacs ligne et
j'en passe ce qui ne permet pas de
rendre le domaine vraiment accessible
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de parler
transformation numérique sont
technologies finalement une espèce
d'introspection collective quand on
parle digital comme vous le disait un
certain nombre de techniques et de
technologie de termes que finalement on
apprend en cours
mais ce n'est pas un cours que je
voulais donner aujourd'hui ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que quand j'ai
décidé de parler de ce sujet je me suis
dit que ce n'était pas un sujet nous
oh par contre ce qui est toujours
d'actualité c'est qu'aujourd'hui en
france il y à des millions de postes
disponibles dans le numérique
d'un côté et de l'autre des milliers de
candidats qui souhaiteraient peut-être
changer de métier qui souhaiteraient au
passage doper leur salaire ou tout
simplement améliorer leur qualité de vie
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fracture
numérique
alors bonne nouvelle un certain nombre
de dispositifs existent et certaines
entreprises jouent le jeu comme wiztivi
qui est spécialisée dans les interfaces
utilisateurs et les services pour
mobiles tablettes et télévisions ils
sont passés de 50 salariés en 2010 est à
160 aujourd'hui
alors pour la petite histoire ils ont
entre autres recruté un ancien
archéologues pour faire du développement
web
moi j'ai grandi avec indiana jones
ça m'a fait un petit peu sourire alors
vous vous dites peut-être c'est bien
beau mais moi je suis né dans cette ère
du tout numérique
j'ai grandi avec la panoplie digital
bref vous êtes tous des accros aux actes
awad a qu à tabac dès qu est ce que vous
connaissez ne s'agit pas d'un nouveau
sport une pratique sportive hybride ni
d'un nouveau plat vegan trouver sur ping
terrestre mais un terme une terminologie
que je traduirai pour l'occasion à
n'importe quel moment n'importe où pour
n'importe quel support et pour n'importe
quel type de contenu le monde du travail
se décloisonne adieu la logique de silos
des personnes travaille avec des gens à
l'autre bout du monde avec des
freelances des indépendants comme je le
suis
avec des collègues qui travaillent de
chez eux en home office ou des personnes
qui travaillent dans des espaces de
travail partagés et tout ça grâce aux
outils collaboratifs digitaux d'où
l'intérêt pour moi et pour nous tous
évidemment de s'y intéresser
quand on se dit ça là je vous ai donné
les aspect plus professionnel
d'un point de vue personnel j'ai initié
le mouvement par réel besoin
une espèce d'évidence je dirais presque
une révélation divine
non pas vraiment ce serait un petit peu
facile d'enclencher ce genre de démarche
en un claquement de doigts je dirais que
c'est le cumul de plusieurs éléments
le premier j'ai passé 35 ans marié deux
enfants
rien de faire ce constat vous verrez
vous donne l'impression d'être sur une
route toute tracée
le deuxième j'avais un job passionnant
plutôt prenant avec peu de perspectives
d'évolution nous ne sommes pas piquer le
boulot de mon chef mais j'en avais pas
très envie et le dernier constat c'est
un l'évolution de mes valeurs et surtout
le sentiment de ne plus être aligné avec
elle c'est donc petit à petit étape par
étape avec des périodes de doute de peur
même de sortir de ma zone de confort que
j'ai décidé de me mettre en action pour
ma propre quête de sens alors ce projet
de reconversion aînés et pour moi a
vraiment vocation à répondre à un
certain nombre d'objectifs et vous allez
voir il y en a pas mal
le premier c'est apprendre à prendre
dans un monde qui évolue vite et je
dirais que c'était c'est essentiel dans
l'univers du marketing
le deuxième un besoin de renouveau
changer et surtout quitter l'entreprise
dans laquelle j'avais grandi pendant 15
ans ensuite j'avais besoin de changer de
perspective de travailler à
l'international dans le monde entier et
revenir à une dynamique plus local
j'avais aussi envie de profiter de
l'agilité du monde entrepreunarial et la
haute savoie n'est pas en reste pour
cela bien sûr j'avais surtout envie d'un
point de vue personnel d'allier ma vie
familiale à cette aventure
professionnelle et je dirais comme nous
tous me rendre utile
j'avais le souhait de m'engager sur des
activités bénévoles et associatives en
particulier dans le domaine du sport et
pour finir ça en fait déjà pas mal ça
c'est un peu un truc d'anciens j'avais
envie de transmettre transmettre oui
mais recevoir des enseignements en
retour est ce que certains en doutent
encore mais on en apprend beaucoup en
côtoyant les jeunes que vous êtes
le résultat c'est qu'aujourd'hui je suis
consultante et j'accompagne des jeunes
entreprises des entrepreneurs alors
d'ailleurs jeunes et moins jeunes dans
le déploiement stratégique et digitales
de leurs projets alors justement quand
on sait qu'en france on a à peu près dix
mille entreprises jeunes entreprises qui
se créent et que près de la moitié
doivent fermer leurs portes
au bout des trois ans de leur première
vie les premières années de vie autant
dire que j'ai du boulot quoi
je suis également professeur vacataire
dans cette université je me suis engagé
sur des activités bénévoles et
associatives et je flexibilise mon
activité pour profiter de mes enfants
énormément de d'activités différentes
des rencontres multiples et riches en
fait je suis devenue une pro du slash il
n'y plus j'ai de l'expérience et moins
j'ai de certitudes et plus je me remets
en question et plus je m'ouvre aux
autres et à mon environnement
l'agilité dont tout le monde parle et
mon prédécesseur également naissent tout
simplement pas ça être à l'écouté
cherchent et se cherche et grandir un
retour à l'enfance finalement et à ce
propos nous voilà arrivés à ma deuxième
transformation
j'irai l'inclusion digitale de mes
filles mon aîné roxane vient de rentrer
au collège tik tok snap chatte youtube
voilà vous voyez de quoi je parle
ma cadette morgan qui a 7 ans est tombée
amoureuse de notre assistant vocal alex
à la semaine dernière dans la voiture
alex ans il fait quel temps demain donc
moi c'est maman pas alexa est ce que je
dois m'acquitter votre avis voilà on
parle de génération connectée
non non pas chez moi
ba ainsi carrément cichy alors en plus
je travaille dans le digital
donc nous avons smartphones mobiles
tablettes ordinateurs
le tout au pluriel netflix difficile de
faire abstraction du monde qui nous
entoure et en même temps tous ses outils
et ses supports nous aide dans notre
quotidien nous permettre de nous
organiser et nous permettent de rester
connectés avec notre communauté
finalement un bar du coin 4.0
la communauté est une force dont le
digital est un catalyseur
quel que soit votre âge votre parcours
votre génération
vous avez la possibilité de changer
changer de vie changer tout simplement
de boulot changer d'environnement vous
épanouir tout simplement mon leitmotiv
aujourd'hui à prendre continuellement
il me serait impossible de vous dire les
prochains bouleversements que
connaîtront maïs je me dis que cet
épisode est le premier de plein d'autres
transformations plein d'autres bons là
changement dans ma vie l'université de
savoie fête ses 40 ans je soufflerai
mais quarante bougies l'année prochaine
en me souhaitant le meilleur dans tous
ces changements et j'aurai une pensée
pour vous qui connaîtrait votre première
transformation quitter la vie étudiante
pour le monde du travail avec un champ
de possibles presque infinies et j'aurai
une pensée pour virginie redvers donc du
club des entreprises que vous devez
connaître qui elle prendra son dernier
virage professionnel la retraite
alors êtes vous prêt pour vos prochaines
transformation
pour ceux qui le souhaitent puisque nous
avons parlé communauté j'enclenche
serait l'option à proximité de linkedin
donc restons connectés merci
[Applaudissements]